hey 42 here in 1846 the daily news
became London's newest newspaper its
editor-in-chief was none other than
author Charles Dickens welcome to RIF
diamonds are actually unstable at
surface temperature and pressure every
diamond above ground is very very slowly
altering into graphite another form of
pure carbon it is impossible to spell a
word using only the bottom row of a
QWERTY keyboard medieval Japanese
samurai burned incense in their helmets
so that if they were decapitated in
battle their head would smell sweet the
lion costume in the film Wizard of Oz
was made from real lions the s in harry
s truman didn't stand for anything
Truman had a middle initial but no
middle name owls are not only carnivores
but also cannibals who may eat over
hours of a different species most
supermarkets placed their bakery areas
near the entrance because studies have
shown that the aroma of fresh baked
goods makes customers spend more money
despite being staples of the Old West
landscape neither horses nor tumbleweeds
are native to North America a baby can
cost new parents 750 hours of sleep in
the first year the first VCR developed
by the UMP X corporation in 1956 weighed
nearly six hundred and eighty kilograms
it took another 15 years before a
commercially viable product hit the sea
Kiribati is the only country that falls
in all four hemispheres only a few
species of dinosaurs ate meat the
majority of dinosaurs were herbivores
goldfish can distinguish the music of
one composer from another the flashes of
colored light that you see when you rub
your eyes are called phosphenes to save
money when you shop don't touch anything
touching an item makes you more likely
to
it and be more willing to pay more for
it thanks for the view subscribe for
more 42